allora ragazzi in questa partita di
among us ho fatto delle robe pazzesche
perché a un certo punto mentre stavo
vincere la partita ho ammazzato un tizio
e charlie se n'è accorta pratica entro
il secondo dopo è stato bellissimo non
ha capito che vi chiedo io quindi
vedrete poi delle cose rispondano a fare
tanto lo vedete quindi buona visione
vorrei uccidere questi infatti lo faccio
tanto stesso stava infatti tanto stesso
stava fk anche a me ma a me che me ne
frega a me che me ne frega a me allora
proviamo a fare un fix lights tattico se
ne escono trova qualcuno in navigation
ma vediamo fix l'ice electrical in free
in giù in white di provenienza c'è
qualcuno che riesca a beccare nel mentre
appare fair è potuto ucciderla cioè che
noi ha subito europeo perfetto che è
morto
siamo hanno riportato è che anche con
l'acqua zard
ma io sono morto ma che non sta affatto
una gamba chiamato e io raga allora sono
andate l'electric all per le luci ho
visto dediche le stava facendo ha
fissato le luci e poi trovato in alto a
destra sempre in electric oil cadavere
ipsia o fine della spagna che fa al sud
ai peperoni scusa e attaccando il pranzo
e la gente net i peperoni ovunque ma per
far cosa
l'accusa d'aver che stai felice se
cagate in partita la cosa non è che
gente brava qua come impostare
allora che abbiamo pagato noi siamo
schifati stesso si fa il complimento
vabbè martin abbiamo perso è votata da
sola anche noi aveva dato lo sai che
noia perché ha trovata trovato troppo
tra l'ato troppo bellissimo va bene mi
sono cagato veramente addosso perché se
che noia ma domani stroke ha detto che è
matto mi segue sa fece una doppia cerca
la doppia cercato piace scala doppia
cerca la doppia cerca la doppia cerca la
doppia cerca le vai di quote di pesca
fare un bel sabato ed di persone
stavolta i giamo matteo fire 4 davide
addetti sta qua
ok ok ok lo possiamo fare perfetto
seguiva da due ore raga che state vuol
fare mi seguiva due ore no chi è stato a
riportarlo niente l'ho trovato in
caffetteria io ho finito netasq so
gironzolando la ricerca di qualche
sospetto non hanno trovato nessuno
quindi bordo i ragazzi non l'ho mai
visto effettivamente neanch'io
grazie grazie congratulazioni a penso ma
vj e gli altri baby forse pesca chigi
meno male che si è votata la sua che
noia sarà un casino
allora ragazzi sono morti già in due
il problema è che non ho idea di chi
possa proprio la minima idea non ho
visto niente anche perché ero al ces
mentre la partita iniziata
no as the family con red che io allora
andiamo qua io alla mia età nonostante
quei ragazzi incredibile che io
nonostante non sia stato in partita
all'inizio l'ho finita e lo stesso le
tasche cioè come come mai la gente non
riesce a far letta io riesco a fare
subito il problema non ho visto niente
era sul corridore video di navigation
via perché mi ha dato subito io ho dato
che noia perché gli impostori palese su
chi sia andata non usa lo dico vedete lo
vediamo dopo mettere altra youtuber qua
io chiamo stessa cose che possono
sembrare ad una primadonna ragazzi basta
votare che noi a caso se non ci finisco
secco va bene buone quindi non possiamo
che noia perché sennò non ha senso sì
quelle elezioni
la cosa di siri non hanno detto eseries
acceso il telefono che sia giusta ma che
ca pensi tu
ragazzi ma che senso ha sta roba no
perché sentivo charlie cerca gli dice
non facciamo le navigation però problema
che c'è la gente sono morte morte quindi
stanno trovando c'è oxygen da fare io
sono a casa mia quindi non ce la farò
mai vendo se ci sono morti in elettrica
non entrano non trovo mai corpi comunque
la vedo io vengo solo richiamato nelle
menti lana di navigation weeps
navigation system per esempio limare la
gente e stavo facendo quelle emergenze
di ossigeno e c'era comunque visti come
quindi mi sembra carino
in ordine e ho visto martina quindi voli
da sole non lo fa questo io non lo vedo
mai il paese per i marchigiani ma perché
sono andato a basaldella
esatto ero lì che cercavo il baiano
comprare scarpe e scarpe leader ll fatto
bene per me io non ho visto matteo
pagani e l'ilo migliorando
secondo unico mattina quindi infatti
infatti cioè io ho cambiato perché se
non sembra troppo sospetto ha dichiarato
perché non ha le scarpe ahiahiahi
persona stili aia brutta testa ai a
niente ragazzo sono curioso di vedere
chi vince sapete che non ho idea di chi
sia sicuramente spicchio guarda ora
chiede soltanto di ammazzare beschi al
cento per cento
l'altro non so chi è che noi è ferma in
mezzo vessicchio sto aspettando eccolo
lì era veramente fare hai visto mai
vabbè loda la corsia della frutta tè
avevo visto bene i ragazzi anche oggi le
partite sono state di vostro gradimento
spero di sì perché io sicuramente sono
contento di come sono andate vi
ringrazio ha visto video ci vediamo alle
prese bisogna cioè tasto mi piace
lasciato un bel commento iscrivetevi al
canale e noi come sempre ci vediamo al
prossimo vino beh ragazzi
[Musica]